it's a great honor for me to sit next to
Jan ships who for us Mormon files as i
call myself i've helped pave the way for
non-mormons to pursue scholarly pursuits
to push the handcart so to speak to use
a mormon expression Paul Bullock pull
the card that shows my outside pole push
so let me dive right into my my talk
next October Barack Obama will square
off against the Republican nominee in
three presidential debates on college
campuses in Colorado New York and in
Florida after a series of Romney
alternatives have sparked and faded and
sparked again the odds of the former
governor of Massachusetts winning the
nomination are still in his favor I
actually checked in trade this morning
which is the site that has become very
popular where you can buy and sell stock
on the presidential election and Romney
was down to after South Carolina 62 he's
back up to eighty eight percent which
for Mormon studies people like me who
hope to get a job one day I'm or
Mercedes is great news but according to
most recent indicators Romney's
much-debated Mormon problem perhaps his
main impediment to the Republican
nomination in 2008 is less of a problem
among the white evangelicals on whom
he'll depend in both the remaining
primaries and general election if romney
does get the nomination one element of
the mormon problem will come into stark
relief under the floodlights in the
college auditoriums hosting the
presidential debates for more than 140
years the Church of Jesus Christ of
Latter day Saints forbid blacks from
full church membership for most of this
time church of his two officials justify
this exclusion by asserting that blacks
for the permanently cursed descendants
of the biblical anti-heroes kane and
canaan black men could not have the
moron priesthood and black couples could
not marry in Mormon temples now in the
media the image of a devout Mormon
trying to unseat ameri
his first black president has already
led to questions about romney's
responsibility to address his church's
so-called black problem on the
huffington post biblical scholar Oh
barium Hendricks a New Yorker insists
that he didn't does not believe in
religious litmus test of any kind quote
yet I must admit there that there is
something about Mitt Romney's religion
that I find deeply troubling unquote
most troubling for hendricks is the
keystone for the latter day saints
movement the book of mormon itself yet
for mormons the often spoken phrase i
believe that the Book of Mormon is true
is part me of the litany of claims that
forms the unofficial LDS confession of
faith the Mormon equivalent to the
Islamic Jihad ah perhaps beginning his
article with a dismissal of religious
litmus tests Hendrickson
african-american ends with an open
letter directed to Governor Romney
demanding that he quote disavow the
portions of your holy book that our soap
that so sorely denigrate the humanity of
me my loved ones and all people of black
African descent unquote according to
Hendrix for Romney to be President of
the United States he must in essence
apostasy on the New York Times his
campaign stops blog Lee's Segal proposes
what is at first glance a counter
intuitive argument for years after the
nation celebrated the election of
America's first black president Segal
posits that Romney's whiteness is the
one quality that has subtly fueled his
candidacy and could put him over the top
in the fall this whiteness is not
actually about actual phenotype it
Telegraph's it signifies the cultural
alternative to America America's first
black president Siegel locates the
incubator of this whiteness in the LDS
Church which he calls the strongest
fashion of pre-civil Rights American
whiteness in seagulls view white
evangelicals can call Mormonism occult
they can also thank God that the LDS
Church denied full black membership
until nineteen seventy eight
safeguarding white American culture so
that it again
Mormon parlance can be restored into the
November 2012 in the latter days of
white American exceptionalism I
contributed to the vetting of the more
of the Mormon and race problem in the
New Republic I situated the history of
Mormon racial exclusion as a conflict
between two major impulses of Mormon
identity a particular lista Cosper
gospel that favors certain ethnic groups
and a universal universalizing call to
teach the gospel to everyone everywhere
I hope to show that the modern Church
has emphasized Mormon universalism over
racial particularity steals today's
church leaders have not reputed
repudiate you pre repudiated the
troubling sentiments statements of the
path of their past predecessors this
silence from the top means that black
Mormons continue to be the targets of
racial slurs in the ward meet in their
ward meeting houses and even in Mormon
temples media criticism is not the
central discipline of my talk clever
instead I wish to narrate his a history
or more precisely histories specifically
multivalent histories about the black
Mormon past the history of the LDS
Church's practice of racial exclusion is
what I call an oft-told tale yet there
are at least two histories of the LDS
Church and its relationship with
african-americans even to pre-1978
histories one of these histories is of
racial exclusion the other history is
one of Mormon empathy even kinship with
african-americans created out of a
shared past a persecution by white or
Gentile America including the failure of
American Constitution constitutional
system to protect basic civil liberties
the second history is not a rebuttal of
the first instead it is a parallel
history that emerges from a different
set of assumptions about Mormons and
their church so this one off told tale
becomes here twice told the goal of my
talk is to narrate both of these
histories by focusing on four aspects of
history of black Mormon relations I will
follow a telling of an aspect of the
history of Mormon racial exclusion with
the telling of the same or similar
aspect from a perspective of normal
Mormon racial inclusion or at least
empathy with african-americans so first
first aspect The Book of Mormon a white
supremacy text and/or a universal gospel
Hendricks is correct that any discussion
of Mormonism and african-americans must
begin with the Book of Mormon itself yet
his exegesis flattened the text to one
single note of white supremacy when it
is in fact mult are complicated multi
voice and prevent prophetic the Nephites
whose historians and prophets kept the
records that would become the Book of
Mormon portray the Lamanites as wicked
and unrighteous with within the first
generations in America the Lamanites
degeneracy was so profound that God
intervened and cursed them with dark
skin God hoped at this demarcation would
would prevent confusion and perhaps
mating between the righteous and white
Nephites and the black skinned Lamanites
whiteness years signifies purity
darkness signifies impiety and
unworthiness this perspective influenced
the way early Mormons view dark-skinned
people take for example the may 1844
patriarchal blessing James Jane Manning
James received from Hyrum Smith in this
patriarchal blessing James is marked as
a descendant of the cursed lineages of
Canaan son of ham she is not of the
Royal lineages of Ephraim manessa or
Jacob designated as the progenitors of
most early latter-day saints Hyrum tells
Jane that this curse this quote mark
upon your forehead unquote that god
himself placed god though can remove and
stamp upon you his own lineage if that
is she and her kin remained faithful to
the gospel now I 2012 reading of the
book of mormon's position that whiteness
is close to godliness is disturbing but
the Book of Mormon is not solely a text
of white or neo Israelite
supremacy it also teaches of the
possible redemption of all humanity even
those are cursed with dark skin Jamie
Manning James can work to have the mark
of Canaan removed from our forehead the
patriarchal blessing of Elijah able the
most well known black priesthood holder
ordained during Joseph Smith's lifetime
foretells in the kingdom to come that he
will be quote equal to thy brethren and
thy soul be white in eternity unquote in
an age when Harvard's Louis Agassiz and
other professors of a poly Jenna Scism
gave the rigidity of racial categories
the imprimatur of science mormons
professed the more modern view that
raised was mutable and constructed
blackness signified unworthiness but
blackness wasn't always fixed to black
bodies in 1838 as Willard Richards
described a trustworthy freed slave he
was sending north from Richmond to his
brother in Boston quote black skin may
cover as white a heart as any other skin
and the black hand may be as neat and
clean as the white one unquote now the
converse also held true in March 1845
John Taylor's navvu neighbor declared
the murderers of Joseph and Hyrum who
blacken their faces before the assault
on the Carthage Jail quote no doubt are
sorry that they have white skin the
black masks have made their faces course
the black masks made their faces
correspond to with their quote black
hearts unquote black men and women can
become white and worthy through their
dedication to the gospel white men
become black for their perfidy and
anti-mormon violence now certainly today
The Book of Mormons conceptions of
whiteness as the mark of worthiness
makes us squirm in our seats yet for the
book of mormon's earliest believers
whiteness was both a real racial
category and a signifier of worthiness
that can be applied to all who prove
themselves worthy and dedicated to the
mormon gospel aspect to Joseph Smith
a slavery apologist or and an
abolitionist presidential candidate in
April in an April 1836 article published
in the messenger and advocate Joseph
Smith presented a defense of American
chattel slavery that could have been
written by any Antebellum pro-slavery
apologist Smith excoriated northern
abolitionists as instigators of discord
among southern slaves if slaves and
slave masters live by the code of
paternalistic mutual obligation used
freakazoided apologist cited ephesians 6
for this paternalistic code often slaves
obeying their masters the master is
caring for their slaves both bondsman
and master would fulfill their biblical
mandated duties creating a society
creating societies of Christian unity
prosperity and peace eight years later
as Professor Bushman has already spoken
up about Joseph Smith the one-time
pro-slavery apologist became the gradual
gradual abolitionist candidate for the
presidency of the United States
frustrated that leading politicians
refused to protect Mormons
constitutionally mandated civil rights
Smith decided to run for president and
smell himself Smith opens his
presidential platform by declaring that
the ongoing Worman Worman persecutions
have shown that when it comes to the
ideals of the Declaration of
Independence namely that God shall
protect the God excuse me that
government shall protect the god-given
rights of life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness Mormons need not apply
hundreds of our kindred have been
incarcerated Smith declared unjustly
detained for practicing their faith but
Joseph persecuted religious minority was
actually second on his list of Americans
whom the government had most had most
egregiously failed the men and women
most in need of reparation were some two
or three million millions of people who
aren't held as slaves because the color
of their skin now slaves and Mormons
here made kin in prayer in general
Smith's
presidential platform by unlawful
bondage and unconstitutional persecution
third aspect Utah slavery and Utah
freedom in February 1852 Utah's first
territorial legislature made slavery
legal from the outside the legalization
of slavery in Utah meant that the twin
relics of barber barbarism as the 1856
Republican presidential platform called
them called slavery in polygamy were
both now in practice in Zion the
introduction of slavery was also noticed
and derided by the most famous black man
in America Frederick Douglass in the
North Star and in the Frederick Douglas
Douglas papers Douglas had before
printed empathetic reports of the
Mormons his fault expulsion from
Illinois in which he implied kinship
with this relay which was religious sect
who like african-americans were often
deemed enemies to the white American
Republic and as such were frequent
victims of judge Lynch's vigilante
violence only when Brigham Young moved
to legalized slavery in Utah did
Douglases paper make mention of polygamy
for the first time equating it as did
many anti polygamists with the
institution of chattel slavery itself
yet with the Republicans in Douglas fail
both fail to realize is that Utah
slavery was not the same as the peculiar
institution practice in the south
certainly Young's decision had a lot to
do with placing Mormon slave masters on
the right side of law however more than
the so-called Negro problem it was the
Indian problem that led to the
legalization of slavery in utah by
regulating slavery LDS leaders hope to
curb the lucrative trade of Indian
slaves along the old Spanish Trail that
passed through the territory motivated
by mormons unique geological views and
compassion for Indian slaves who are
mostly women and children captured from
weaker tribes Mormons hope to buy
enslaved slaved Indians into freedom
place them in Mormon homes the children
or marry them to Mormon
and transforming these savages and this
is the language they use into civilized
Lamanites one step closer to making them
white and delightsome Young and his
legislature intended to differentiate
Utah system of slavery in two
fundamental ways first under the threat
of prison a hefty fine and the
forfeiture of ownership Utah outlawed
quote carnal intercourse with African
slaves sleeping with your slaves was
both a story pastime for southern
masters and a means of increasing your
wealth secondly let the legislature made
it a duty of all masters to educate
their slaves to send them to school for
no less than 18 months and this was in
the legislation legislative laws this
compulsory education in Utah shouldn't
stood in sharp contrast with the
southern practice of compulsory
ignorance in which most states in the
antebellum South criminalized slave
education out of fear that reading and
writing slaves might lead to slaves in
revolt Young was no Joseph Smith during
the same legislative session he made his
position on the inherent distinction
between worthy whites and a Kirsten
blacks unequivocal and this often
perhaps too often repeated phrase any
man as he said any man having one drop
of seed of Cain in him cannot hold the
priesthood as he said yeah yet young
also made it clear that he deplored
personally the Plourde slavery my own
feelings are that no property can or
should be recognized as existing in
slaves wither Indian or African unquote
if slavery had to come to Utah and Jung
believed it did ironically as a means of
liberating Indians it would not be the
slavery practiced by the so-called
Christian southern slave masters it
would be a more benign even Mormon form
of the institution fourth and last point
jumping ahead about a hundred years the
civil rights era to a denial and a
rediscovery of a black
ormond passed during the civil rights
era the LDS LDS Church's leadership was
famous for its recalcitrance towards
changing views of race in America until
his death in 1973 church historian
turned Church President Joseph fielding
Smith who is the most famous articulator
of the pre-existence thesis of black
occur sadness publicly defended the
immutability of the priesthood
restriction time and again he insisted
the practice was consistent with the
teachings of Joseph Smith and
established by the Lord there had never
been black priesthood holders and the
and thus there had never been a black
woman passed during the 1950s and 60s
many brethren declared that not only
were blacks ineligible for the
priesthood that the danger that their
cursed blood white soil pure lineages
meant that the church discouraged
interracial marriage and until nineteen
sixty three many church leaders
supported racial segregation now not all
leading Mormons agreed with the Brethren
stance Mitt Romney today proudly boasts
of his father's pro-slavery or excuse me
40 civil rights stands that would be a
significant problem ah
the Democratic US secretary of the
interior interior Stewart Udall probe
proposed an alternative more mid
position when it came to
african-americans in America in a
much-publicized nineteen sixty sixty
seven letter addressed to the church's
first presidency Udall declared that
quote the restriction now imposed on
Negro Fellowship is a social and
institutional practice having no real
sanction in essential Mormon thought it
is clearly contradictory to our most
cherished spiritual and moral ideals
unquote now the Brethren did not get
like getting lectured to and told you it
all directly but in some ways they
listened to the growing chorus outside
the hierarchy and some actually
certainly within it who found the
perpetuation of the priesthood ban
untenable a 1969 statement from the
church's First Presidency reduced the
band to a mystery of faith an urge
Mormons to patiently await the Lord to
overturn it yet the First Presidency
narrated also narrated a past a
persecution shared by both blacks and
Mormons quote we know something of the
sufferings of those who are
discriminated against in a denial of
their civil and constitutional
privileges we believe that the Negro
should have full constitutional
privileges as a member of society
unquote this is the same year that the
LDS Church was or brigham young
university had become kind of notorious
for being for being the target of
protests against our football team so
let me end this brief discussion of the
civil rights era by pointing to another
pressure point apply to the priesthood
band historians yes historians mostly
Mormons themselves but also with
important interventions by the likes of
our own gene ships whose first article
actually addressed the priesthood ban in
nineteen in a time before proved that
the band was a historical accretion not
based on any specific revelation or
sacred scripture Lester bush Lester
Bush's exhaustive 10-year study of
church
kurds found no evidence that Joseph
Smith himself started the band the main
argument the church hierarchy had used
to justify it for over a century over
the particularistic doctrine that
limited the full rights of the gospel to
a select set of ancient lineages these
historians found at the church that the
early church emphasized Mormon
universalism a universalism that
rejected the puritanical ideal that the
puritanical idea that the sons even the
purported sons of Cain and Canaan to be
held responsible for the sins of their
fathers and I think this is one of the
most fundamental aspect of Mormon
theology is the rejection of of the the
sins of the fathers falling onto the
sons now to conclude a few questions I'd
like to end the telling of the history
of black Mormon relations as it was as a
twice-told tale by posing three
questions about how these histories
might finger figure into today's
discussions first does Romney have to
say more about Mormonism and race either
out of political expediency or out of
some moral or theological obligation
this will continue to come up the LDS is
relationship with it it's it's black
membership if Romney gets the nomination
even today there are new articles being
published in his new york times article
Lee Siegel asked perhaps poorly as
Joanna Brooks so eloquently pointed out
if this is both I think the implicit
message of its article is is this both a
Mormon and a black moment in American
presidential politics in other words as
the national lecturer debates whether or
not it is comfortable with a Mormon as
president has the election of barack
obama really proven that america is
comfortable with a black president
finally let me pose a counterintuitive
question on romney's pursuit of a
republican nomination the oft old
history of mormon racial exclusion
suggests that romney has in fact a black
problem yet gingrich is chief rival to
the nomination continues to engage in
what some pundits have called
dog-whistle racial politics namely
calling Obama the food stamp president
for example in this environment at least
I'm talking about the Republican
nominating process in this environment
can Romney make his increasingly
racially universalistic Mormon faith a
political asset if you direct directly
directly addresses this in other words
does the Mormon Mitt Romney really have
to have a black problem thank
we have time for questions i'm wondering
if ovaries here actually i haven't seen
him but please please if you would first
of all I'd like to thank you all very
much for this is very very valuable than
educational conference and just a quick
ID quick i self ID before I asked my
very quick question if I may please go
ahead I'm former US Department of State
for inserting Mitt Romney was boy
Louisiana's exactly raised Catholic and
bit wayward I respect all he worshipped
kaveh film with orange dr
there is and healthiest I don't know
where to call the church office at
anything else unless I respect the
Mormon Church and missionaries and
welcome country now my question is
properties caster like this one convert
two lbs oh did you ask you to run the
wrong people well my own my own general
answer is the appeal of the family and
the way in which the family figures in
the Mormon story and its appeal to both
people who are and have have families
that are precious to them and people who
do not but hope to and this is so I see
that not as the only but I see that as a
big part of the appeal of Mormonism
wouldn't you say in the 19th century to
a big part of the appeal was the fact
that the Scriptures located divine
activity here in America right here in
the Americas right I think that's that's
very important I think it was as if it
was probably more important in the 19th
century years than it is today but but
today I think that the appeals shifts
and changes across time of course as we
know please
so I'm not sure how many people know
this here but it's always interesting to
note that in this election season
there's a third former presidential
candidate the only catch is that he's
not in the United States commanding
Gaius ommegang is running for a black
man is running for the presidency of the
country of Mali ninety percent Muslim
country in Saharan sub-saharan Africa
now I wanted to ask it's it's really
interesting to consider in this case
from tons of different standpoint I
wanted to ask mr. Mueller whether he
would see this candidacy being noticed I
haven't heard any coverage outside of
utah newspapers and if ya esta mccabe
were elected president of Mali what sort
of effect would that have on perceptions
of moorim black relations especially
when oftentimes as you have noted they
are caricatured yeah actually I've met I
attended a rally or a fundraiser in in
the valley in the Utah Valley for the
mayor he's a mayor in in Mali and and
his running on his record as a mayor and
Molly of really changing the biggest
thing he helped to do was increase this
tax tax revenue in his in his in his
community not unlike Italy or Greece in
Mali they were having a hard time
collecting getting folks to pay up their
taxes so we went from ten percent rate
of tax attacks increased to 68 to 70
percent which you know is an important
you know source of revenue for
governmental support of the people yeah
um he's certainly a fascinating man I
think you're I wonder about his
political viability actually in Mali he
claims to be a front front runner but
you know a lot of people claim to be in
front Joseph Smith
one time claimed to be a front-runner in
1844 um but let me address let me speak
to the African aspect of African Mormon
relations the biggest growth area in
black Mormonism is certainly in Africa
and I'm on a lot of black Mormon blogs
or I follow them quite regularly and a
lot of black or african converts I mean
this is a huge growth area partly
because they African Americans frankly
have a preconceived notion of what they
know what the LDS church is about um
when african-americans convert to
mormonism in some ways they get it from
frankly from both sides I mean in some
ways often they're a black their
african-american communities ostracize
them and they don't necessarily feel not
always no don't necessarily feel that
comfortable as black Mormons in fact I
would say that the gathering occurs
african-american members move to Utah if
a gathering still exists in in Mormonism
but that would be a huge tube to have
African presidential you know a
president in Africa I can imagine
temples I can imagine a safe zone in a
very contentious space in Africa from
which the LDS Church could spread its
message and and talk about a great PR
coup also other questions
I have a quite I mean do we have a live
question my first question was a sincere
question what do we think does Romney
have a responsibility to say anything I
think that's a lot of questions somebody
want to take that up before we we move
on to the next question God please
I just wanted to make a quick comment
and ask questions as well just on a
question of conversion I think that just
from as a warm and I think most Mormons
would probably say conversion is is
because of kind of base in our artist
mala G and since that you know having
having had a very profound experience
with the Holy Spirit that for me at
least was unlike nothing else I've ever
experienced in this lifetime you know
brought a very deep conviction for Nia
the truth of the gospel is you know me
to feel closest in connection with God
to me that's more in terms of Appeal I
think family and all but in terms of
conversion that my personal experience
but I just wanted to ask jenn Shipton
could you said about you talk about
Benson and Hubie Brown and I believe
Hubie Brown once akkadian in a
democratic thing and I was wondering if
you knew anything more about about how
that interaction took place where you
said he's sort of asked him you know was
the influence to bring him back from
pushing that perspective on the church
of the whole I think the best source for
that information is Greg princes a
biography of david o mckay because there
are lots of references in there too
David o mckay and Ezra Taft Benson the
story of the his being saved from being
on the John Birch magazine is in there
as well I think that's the best and so I
would I would go there first and i will
tell you that to try to read there's not
a there's not a good biography that i
can find of Ezra Taft Benson there is a
there is a there there are several books
on Ezra Taft Benson but they don't tell
his entire story in any way the way that
biography of David o mckay does tell the
story the Hubie Brown book his
references in his book to Ezra Taft
Benson are all just he is a wonderful
latter-day Saint they're all his a
friend and so forth but they when we but
in the 60s when we were in Utah there
was a lot of conversation among
non-mormons I mean not i don't mean non
warrant I mean what we were taught as
Jack Morris then people who who were who
were Mormons who had never asked to have
their names remove considered themselves
Mormon but they just weren't active and
the cocktail party conversation was
often about what was going on inside the
12 so that's though that's the way i was
just fascinated by greg princess not
only his book but he has shared with me
the Diaries and it's very interesting I
don't want to eliminate the religious
angle of this but and I'm certainly
aware that Ezra Taft Benson is
conservative politics did have very
great influence on Norman folk
especially in the western states but I'm
wondering if anyone has ever studied
they increasing conservatism of Utah in
the context of the larger region my
understanding is that Utah's neighbor
states have also become much more
Republican and much more conservative
Idaho Wyoming Nevada Arizona and that
the non mormon Westerners have as a
whole become much more conservative and
much more Republican and I'm wondering
if it's possible do you think they're
factor out how much of this bright would
shift is it due to the purely warming
influence of sotf denson and larger
political forces that are moving non
warm and Westerners in that very same
direction I'm not quite sure that you
can really factor out the Mormon vote in
the other states in the Mormon culture
region but in a wonderful essay written
by Kathleen flake she does a very
interesting parallel between or variance
news story between idaho and utah and
she divides the southern part of Idaho
Idaho which is very Mormon and the
northern part of idaho and and makes it
clear that both are going through the
same economic problems the same issues
that are facing people in the West and
and especially water is a big big
problem for people in West so I'm not
quite sure that if you got a water
problem you'd become a radical
conservative but it might be one of the
issues that is extremely important one
commonality all Westerners that's
everyone eats the lamb that's true but
but they didn't hate that but they
didn't hate the landlord in the New Deal
they didn't take the landlord in the New
Deal the landlord was very very helpful
yeah I'm the other the other factor that
kind of goes along with that question
was James Watt and the sagebrush
rebellion of course wat became Secretary
of the Interior under Reagan hi my name
is rachel moore st i just wanted what
you were asking about
strikes me there's a interesting
parallel between that situation and
those who would consider themselves be
politically liberal evangelicals yeah
it's the thing this is no shocker there
a game mormons i guess i can say i'm
privileged to know about that since I
told a national
imagine seminar both in salt lake city &
provo some years ago and because I was
there for an entire summer and because I
could read Hebrew which was fascinating
to those discovered it I will embrace my
lots of Mormon families outside of my
professional responsibilities and was
invited several times to meetings covert
meetings of lesbians and gay males and
sometimes coed so to speak so it is
though shocked at me and probably
shouldn't be to anyone else but this is
a political question the church or its
shall we say advocates for involved a
few years ago in California in
supporting public initiative and with
regard to gay marriage is there a
dimension of this which is analogous
question in terms of welcoming or not
welcoming capacities between blacks and
mormons and in a historical sense is
there another part of the story that we
need to know more about with regard to
the attitude towards homosexuality
perspective part of that story will be
revealed I think this afternoon in one
of the sessions but it's a fair question
and fee the panelist wants to take it
yeah theological e I think the step just
speaking theologically to include
african-americans into the discipline
see you know into the full dispensation
is as as us not as much of a sleep
theologically speaking because of the
essential nature of the Mormon family
and the heterosexual Mormon family as
part of the sociology you know the idea
of the Eternity of the husband and wife
connected together so um so I don't know
how much of a parallel they directly
parallel a direct parallel that can be
you made I just want to say though
though just like there are democratic as
you pointed out there there are game or
be gay morons just like there are
democratic Mormons there are folks in
the in the church that are actively
participating with the Brethren to have
a more open discussion about these
issues and and are a lot of latter-day
saints there disheartened as we will
find out later by some of the activities
track political act before regarding the
game Decker I was born and raised here
in New York City and my parents are
Greek interprets the Greek New Yorker I
became a member of the church by through
an acting school that I was part of and
with only two gay Mormons these two day
more than reduced me to the church that
brought me into the church now far the
your coats on the borders and black and
follow the politic very closely with
Luclin and blackish shoe never really
had been really on my mind much for
joining Romney and the Republicans we
all know that ninety percent are going
to vote Democrat anyway but can be an
issue that can play on my biggest
concern in the evangelical becoming less
and less
time if you have the core evangelicals
some of them in leadership positions
that are fiendishly handsy Mormon no
bone and I think South Carolina one of
the reason why the Super Tuesday coming
up in March making rich some subtraction
but the angelika issue what you're
speaking of the argument that Mormonism
is not Christian is the evangelical
position and the evangelical position is
it seems to me easier to answer by
saying that it is Mormonism is not
Christian the way Protestants and
Catholics are Christian and you can you
can make that case and then all you have
to say is is there a Supreme Court on
the earth that decides who is Christian
and who is not but that that may be a
little much for for the for the for the
world out there but it seems to me that
I Romney learned a lot in 2008 to stop
using evangelical language to describe
his Mormonism he it was it just was no I
know it is I know I didn't Richard Lando
I'm on the night of the South Carolina
but right before the new the results
working we're going to go towards
towards Gingrich but Richard land on NPR
actually drug directly addressed this
issue Wichard land is certainly one of
the most prominent evangelical leaders
in the country as part of the
Baptist Convention and he said the
Mormonism isn't Mitt Romney's problem in
fact if he were more this is Richard
land speaking if you were more Mormon if
you were more in line with his church
now we can debate whether or not this is
correct on issues of same-sex marriage
issues of abortion uh then his
conservative bona fides would never be
in question so um and you know that's
that's Richard land speaking in South
Carolina Richard land also last year
said that Mormonism is not Christian so
you know he's willing I think to make a
political alliance with Mormonism
conservative political I it's not unlike
the Catholic even Protestant alliance I
think Richard land is Evan Jellicle isms
or Ezra Taft Benson haha well well it
seems to me having grown up in the South
that if Romney is is the candidate they
the evangelicals and the Protestants in
the south will hold their nose and vote
for him because they prefer a a Mormon
who is a funny kind of Christian than a
black person
okay then brah the hate for Barack Obama
so much that that's my dog that's what
we'll find out it's twelve o'clock
exactly will conclude with our thanks to
this panel and reconvene at one o'clock